this is the team's third expedition to
these shark-filled waters below Mexico's
Guadalupe Island captain Brett knows
this harsh environment
well the island itself kind of beers
what goes on underwater they just look
up there this much hospitable rugged
like you would have a hard time
surviving anywhere up there you can get
hurt really easy just like right here in
the water
la de Lupe is one of a handful of
locations around the world where great
whites gather and doctor Domeier thinks
they come here to breed for many years I
thought that white sharks are very
likely mating at these adult aggregation
sites but I've never been able to figure
out a way to prove that by having these
white sharks on the deck of the boat I
was able to start looking her stuff like
blood hormone levels and sperm finding a
sperm was the first thing that really
started pick up this idea yes they are
mating here but I couldn't just say I
saw sperm I had to actually collect it
and and and stain it and put it
underneath the microscope and take a
picture to prove it to the world hang on
we got something just yesterday he
thought he finally had a good sperm
sample from a 14-foot male named a bite
face
but he and associate Nicole Lucas
quickly discover they were wrong
there's our sample it's the right color
we might have a sperm cell here but it
is not moving it was his first attempt
to examine great white sperm under a
microscope it's not sperm swimming all
around in this sample I kind of expected
to see things wiggling around later he
recognized his mistake he needed to look
for something called a spermatophore and
the seminal fluid sorry reproduction is
a bit different than what you might
expect the sperm in males actually comes
out in these little packets called
spermatophores and it look like grains
of rice so I'll be looking for those on
this trip now 24 hours later he needs a
new sperm sample to try and isolate
those grain like patterns it's the proof
he needs to finally determine if males
are here to mate